You play the part of a man
like you are a lost boy.
Give us the powers.
Or we could annihilate everything.
Oh, you're totally serious.
All right, here's the situation.
The wizard gave me superpowers.
Well, then everybody got superpowers.
I know that Daughters of Atlas
are coming to haunt us,
but we come bearing gifts.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
That's why that's a hard pass.
That's a hard pass.
Look,
I might not have as much experience as you
because I'm not, like, super old,
but I've seen all of the Fast
and the Furious movies,
and it's all about family.
Family? Guys.
That was the signal
Yeah, we do
stick to saving the world, kid.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
They just released a new Shazam Fury
of the Gods trailer with Wonder Woman.
Obviously. Big deal.
They finally confirm she's in the movie.
I guess they really want people
to buy tickets for the movie.
So they're showing you that Wonder
Woman is in there.
So it's a much bigger deal
than we previously believed.
It's a bit like the Black Adam movie,
where the Rock revealed that
Henry Cavill
Superman had a cameo scene in Black Adam.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I will do a full breakdown Post-Credits
scene video after the movie comes out.
There are actually two post-credits
scenes,
so if you do get a chance to see the movie
early,
please don't put spoilers for that
in the comments.
I'm supposed to see the movie next week
so I will post a review video
as soon as they let us do that.
But the big deal here obviously
confirming that Wonder Woman from the DCU
is inside this movie
because technically it's still the DCU.
It hasn't completely rebooted in the James
Gunn's DCU until the events of Superman
Legacy that they're slowly in the process
of doing that through the flash movie
we'd heard a long time ago
that Wonder Woman was in this movie.
But there was a big question as to
because of all the reboots
and the fact that they canceled
Wonder Woman three whether or not
they removed her cameo scene
because they also had a Henry Cavill
Superman
cameo seen during the Flash movie,
which we know that they removed.
So I know there's a lot of questions
now, like,
why did Wonder Woman
get to be in Shazam Fury of the Gods?
But they didn't let Henry Cavill
Superman be in the Flash movie
in the way the director of the movie
and then separately,
James Gunn talked about it,
is that as long as their cameo
seems like whoever it is
they want to show up from the Justice
League doesn't completely violate
the new canon that James Gunn is trying
to create with the DCU, then it's okay.
So I think the idea is that
whatever they're doing with Wonder Woman
in this movie,
it doesn't completely break the timeline
that James going to trying to set up
because some of the characters
will have a slightly different backstory.
Like we have a new version of Batman
that's going to show up in Batman,
braving the Bolt,
a new version of Superman.
That's not Henry Cavill there.
The whole Paradise Lost series
that's meant to take place before Wonder
Woman was born, which is the whole reason
why they canceled Wonder Woman three
But the interesting thing is,
is that James Gunn said that he has recast
Gal Gadot as Wonder Woman.
Like she could come back as Wonder Woman.
It's just that
they have to wait till after she's born.
After this Paradise Lost Them
Obscura series happens,
which is meant to be kind of like
Game of Thrones, but on Themyscira
set more than 5000 years ago
because it's about
how old she is in the DCU.
So whatever Henry Cavill
Superman was doing in the Flash movie,
at the end of that,
that would have broken the timeline.
They could set up a whole bunch of stuff
that they didn't intend on paying off.
And whatever Wonder Woman
is doing in Shazam Fury of the Gods,
she's not setting up
a whole bunch of other stuff,
like it's just a quick moment
and it's relatively ambiguous
about what she's been doing before that
and what she's doing after that,
which is how some of these actors
are hoping to come back into
James Gunn's new rebooted DCU.
Like,
as long as they don't completely violate
all the new stuff he's trying to set up,
then there's a small chance
that they could come back.
That's why some of the Shazam
characters are hoping they'll come back.
The only one we know isn't coming back
from sort of that Part of the canon
is The Rock's black Adam.
Like he's basically said he's done with DC
and I don't really consider it
a scoop or anything, but James Gunn
did just revealed that he's been talking
to Henry Cavill about coming back
as a different character in the DCU.
That's not Superman.
You can let me know in the comments
who you think Henry Cavill would play
if it's not going to be Superman.
Zachary Levi Seems like he's trying to do
everything he can to come back though.
But if you remember the earlier trailers,
Wonder Woman
was actually a big part of those,
because when he goes to the child
therapist to talk about the dreams
that he's having, about
how he feels inadequate as a superhero
and he looks up to the Justice League,
he mentions Batman, he mentions everybody
else, Superman, The Flash, Wonder Woman.
There are bunch of Justice
League Easter eggs inside his office.
And even though they play
kind of for a joke,
I believe he's also supposed
to have fantasies
about going out with Wonder Woman.
So there's supposed to be a couple of
jokes about her appearing in the movie,
and then she really appears for real,
Like they really pay it off
at the end of the movie
when she actually shows up.
I think the idea is that earlier
in the movie, it's
meant to be more of a joke
with other characters
pretending to be Wonder Woman
and then later in the movie,
then it's actually wonder Woman,
because the way that they put that scene
in the trailer
there, it actually seems like that Wonder
Woman cameo scene is at the very end
of the movie, like they put
the end of the movie in the trailers,
which is very on brand
for a lot of big comic book movies.
They did the same thing
for the Black Adam movie,
where they put part of that Henry Cavill
cameo scene at the very end of the film.
That Post-Credits scene
in the last couple of trailers.
But I think part of the joke here
with her actual cameo scene
is that she's just giving Billy
a bit of a pep
talk, like a bit of a moment
where she says,
Oh, you know,
you're actually doing a pretty good job.
Just focus on trying to save the world
as she walks away.
And that's about it.
I think there's some other bigger plot
related stuff she's doing.
I don't want to get into too many spoilers
in case it winds up being right, though
I believe she's a relatively critical
part of the movie,
but her appearance in the film
is relatively short,
which is a very important
part of the movie,
and it happens right at the end, but
amongst all the Justice League characters,
because we did have
a Superman cameo in the first movie, why
they would go to one woman in this movie
is because most of the gods were Shazam
gets his powers from or Greek gods.
Not every single one, but most of them.
So it's basically the same pantheon,
the same mythology,
like they're talking about the Greek
Titan Atlas
that comes from Greek mythology,
which is where Wonder Woman comes from.
She comes from the Greek gods.
So it makes sense to be some overlap
between those characters.
And it sounded like a couple of years ago
Zachary Levi been saying that
he wanted to get Wonder Woman
crossover in their movies at some point.
The whole idea in the movie, though,
is that you have these three sisters
that are meant to be the daughters
of the Titan Atlas in universe.
The back story is that Atlas was a tyrant.
That the Wizard Shazam a long time ago
helped stop and took his powers using them
for good,
passing them to each new champion
like he use Atlas Powers to power up
the staff that you see them fighting over.
During the movie,
Helen Mirren is playing Hospira.
The oldest daughter,
Lucy Liu, is playing the middle daughter
Calypso, and Rachel Zegler
is playing the youngest daughter and Thea.
And each one of them has a sort of
different angle in the movie,
even though it seems like
they're all working together.
Really, it's just her spirit and calypso
that want to go after the Shazam.
Only to take the powers
of their father back.
It seems like Rachel Ziegler's
and Thea character wants to help
the Shazam characters and tries to protect
them and her sisters work against her.
During the film.
Like you see her
getting into fights with her sisters.
It also seems like she has
some kind of romance developing
with a Freddie Freeman character
friend of Freddie's.
I hear I am actually. Yeah.
How are you?
You know,
I may be the one with the superpowers,
but that kid, he's the real hero.
Yeah.
I mean, honestly, I've never met anyone
like him.
He's genuine and warm and funny.
That's a lot of nice things.
Yeah.
How did you two meet?
Comic-Con. It's Comic-Con.
All right.
Well,
they had the joke in one of the trailers
about her being 6000 years old
and them saying, Well, you look very good
for someone who's 6000 years old.
It's another Wonder Woman style joke
or Wonder Woman is this really hot
looking woman?
But she's over 5000 years old.
You look really good for your age.
And I believe that Lucy Liu's calypso
character is meant to be the ultimate main
villain of the movie.
Because you see her in all the scenes
where Shazam is like, This is it.
This is our big final fight here.
And you don't see his spirit and you don't
see Anthea in any of those scenes.
So I think the danger in the movie
is that if she gets all the power of their
father back, she'll turn into a tyrant,
just like he was.
They got a couple more scenes
inside the Rock of Eternity.
Now they turned it into their version
of the Batcave.
Just because there are so many Easter eggs
with the Justice
League characters
and all the shows and films.
But it's like the little kids
idea of a Batcave of a lair.
Like what would a little kids bedroom
look like if they could do anything?
They had crazy powers.
So it's got TV's graffiti
just toys all over the place.
They have more jokes about him
trying different doors
to other dimensions and saying nope,
like nope, not going there.
They set that up in the first movie where
there's a place in the Rock of Eternity
that has literal doors
to a bunch of other dimensions.
This place where the three sisters
are from the daughters of the Greek
Titan
Atlas, is meant to be another dimension.
So I think the idea is they use
one of these doors in the Rock of Eternity
to get to this place.
They have a much longer version
of the Fast and Furious joke
that they put
in the last couple of trailers
where the rest of them do show up
when he shouts family,
but only after they botch the payoff,
like they wait too long to show up.
The other joke here, too, is that Helen
Mirren is in the Fast and Furious movies
like she was just in the fast Ten trailer,
which is why they probably went
with the joke in the movie.
In Now Fast
and Furious is Canon to the DCU.
Vin Diesel,
the actor is now Canon to the DCU.
There have also been a couple other scenes
that they've released for the movie too.
Like this is a scene of Billy
revealing his secret
that he is Shazam to his foster mother.
So you kind of get the vibe of the movie.
A lot of this is a balance
between the really funny jokey stuff
like the Fast and Furious style
jokes, the other Justice League jokes,
like the Wonder Woman jokes and cameos
like that big stuff in the heart.
This relationship
that the family shares, like the family
that they made for themselves,
that being a stronger bond,
the Shazam Lee,
than the families that they were born into
because they're all foster children.
Everyone post
all your theories in the comments below.
What do you want them to do with Wonder
Woman in the movies going forward?
If it's going to be several years before
they can actually do another Wonder Woman
movie like they have to wait till after
this Paradise Lost series comes out.
But it does sound like
it's still going to be Gal Gadot.
When Wonder Woman comes back,
I believe I'm allowed to post my review
video on Tuesday.
So look out for that in the My Full
Post-Credits scene video Full Breakdown.
Easter eggs will start posting
at the end of next week
after the movie actually comes out.
Everyone click here for my brand new flash
movie trailer and click here for a brand
new teaser in a scene from the Joker
two movie with Joaquin Phenix.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.